[RETRO GAME BEEPING]
SPEAKER: Identity
Access Management
is how you can decide who does
what with your Google Cloud
resources.
You can get incredibly specific
when you create an IAM policy,
but essentially you have
an identity, a role,
and a resource.
Cloud IAM is designed with a
clean, universal interface,
so you're able to manage
access across all Google Cloud
platform resources consistently,
from App Engine to GCE.
In this hands-on
lab, you'll learn
how to assign a role
to a second user
and remove assigned roles
associated with identity
and access management, or IAM.
During the lab, you'll sign in
with two different user names
to experience how granting
and revoking access
works from both the
viewer and owner role.
Next up on our quest is
Kubernetes engine, Qwik Start.